[Musik]
ein türke mit einem jazz club in berlin
das ist ziemlich ungewöhnlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier sind die kulturinteressierte
menschen haben sowieso die angewohnheit
die musik leben zu lassen und dass
deswegen ist die aufgabe hier um einiges
leichter genau die situation zu
erschaffen die die musik auch wirklich
verdient hat oder braucht und in der
türkei ist es nicht und deswegen bin ich
froh dass ich dann die sind jetzt club
nicht in afrika sondern hier habe fast
täglich steht in berliner aid rain eine
andere band auf der bühne
der club ist für seine intime atmosphäre
bekannt nur rund 200 zuschauer haben
hier platz
das blut ist eine institution in der
deutschen hauptstadt
natürlich wenn die gäste kommen und auch
die freude in ihre geschichte ansehe
dann macht mich das sehr glücklich seit
1997 betreibt sie da ist er dann im
jazzclub da wo ich jetzt auch die bühne
eine ansage machen und ich weiß dass ich
das sehr nervös war er ist stolz dass
hier auch schon die ganz großen musiker
der jazzszene aufgetreten sind zum
beispiel der us amerikanische
jazz-pianist herbie hancock
also musiker wie herbie hancock oder
markus miller die bei mir aufgetreten
sind
das sind einmalige geschichte weil die
tun das um diesen club zu unterstützen
das heißt so ein support gedanke ist
gerade in dem augenblick weil das die
waren auch mal unbekannt jung und wo
haben sie eingefangen nur sind sie wo
haben sie sich entfaltet wo sind sie
groß geworden in den clubs ein stammgast
im hay train ist der deutsche tom
peterzell
er hat seine karriere hier begonnen und
ist immer noch mit zelaya waren
befreundet wann immer er kann kommt er
vorbei
[Musik]
jazz club besitzer sind etwas ganz
besonderes sie sind an der eigenen
spezies sind vor allem deswegen weil
wenn sie nicht gut sind sind sie sofort
weg und keiner spricht über sie passe
dann geht das schon weit über 20 25
jahre mittlerweile wie und das von sich
behaupten kann wieder muss einiges
richtig gemacht
dann kam mit zwölf jahren aus der türkei
nach berlin
den jazz lernte erst später zufällig bei
einer reise in seine heimat kennen und
lieben
er ist hier im berliner bezirk
charlottenburg verwurzelt so viele
einflussreiche kulturschaffende leben
[Musik]
im rennen sollen sich die musiker nicht
nur auf der bühne wohl fühlen
auch vor und nach den konzerten kümmert
sich sega saarbahn um seine gäste denn
er ist nicht nur der besitzer des er ist
auch so eine gute seele
[Musik]